كان احتفال مغربي بامتياز يعني كان عن جد
كنا بعرس مغربي ما شاء الله على المشجعين
على المنتخب على اللعب على طريقه الاداء
على الاشياء كثير بس العلافتني اكثر من
هيك هو التضامن العربي التعادل العربي بين
المشجعين يعني كثير شفنا من السعوديه من
المنتخب السعودي من المشجعين المنتخب
السعودي همم في الملعب كانوا ملعب همم
[تصفيق]
بالضبط
وشفنا كمان من المنتخب التونسي المشجعين
التوانسه شفنا كمان من اليمن شفنا كثير من
العراق من فلسطين من الاردن كثير كانوا
موجودين والحلو بالموضوع احنا تابعنا
المنتخب من الساعات الاولى قبل انطلاق
المباراه ومشينا معهم بعد المباراه الى
منطقه سوق واقف وهنا كان الاحتفال مثل ما
حكيت بالعناوين قبل شوي حصاله حالنا
بجامعنا ساحه جامع الفنا في مراتي
احتفالات اهازيج واشياء كثيره اتفضلي
فبدنا نعرف شو لفهك بالعجائب والطرائف من
احتفالات المشجعين على الارض وانا لانه
مثلا لفتني كثير انه ال ال بيجي عندك ناس
بتتجمع وبتشجع بلد او منتخب مش عم يشارك
اصلا كمان هذا لافت انه ليش
هاي روحي رياضيه اول شيء العجائب الطرائف
اكثر شي عجبني امبارح بصراحه عاده لما
يخرج الجمهور او المشجعين من المباراه
بكون مكتوب ناس حاملين يا قطط مترو ديسواي
فهم المغاربه المنطقه
الثانيه بالمغرب
غير عجبتني شغله مهمه انه في مشجع متحمس
بطريقه بتخوف بشجع مغربي وشاف واحد جزائري
راسا اخذ منه العلم الجزائري تحول ان قلبت
الايه يعني صار المشجع الجزائر المغربي
والمشجع المغربي الجزائر هذا الروح
الرياضيه هذا الحلو بهيك احداث عالميه
التي تحصل يعني الواحد بيعيشها مره بتذكر
تتذكر نادين كنا مع بعض على الهواء بنشره
الاخبار ايام كرواتيا وفرنسا ب 2018 كيف
هجموا علي المشجعين الكروات ويقول لهم على
الهواء
او القميص المنتخب
2018 فهذا الحماس موجود بعد اليوم يعني
بستغرب انه بعدين صغيره
ههه بعدك صغيره شفنا كمان مثلا مشجعه
برازيليه قلت لها كباسه ليش انت موجوده
هون انا انا بحب انا يعني في ناس جايين
يعني انا صرت على يقين انه في جايين مش بس
لتشجيع منتخب بلدهم اجواء المونديال اجواء
مونديال قطر يعني هالسنه مش معقول بيجوا
بس بنتقلو من جهه لجهه وفي منهم بيقولوا
اذا دخلنا على المباراه اتس اوكي واذا ما
دخلنا مش مشكله ابدا بحبه بس التشجيع
والحماس والاجواء المونديال كاس العالم
الموجوده هنا في قطر
المباراه
وفي مترو موجود طول الوقت والمتر على فكره
اسرع عن اكتشفت لو ما معنى المعدات
لازم تكون معنا سياره بس هي الطريقه
مدروسه باخلاص تخرج من الماتش تقدر تروح
على الماتش اللي بعده بتقدر بسهوله بالمتر
وبتوصل على واحد من التمر الملاعب اللي
حكينا عنهم امبارح بصبح العربيه
شكرا جزيلا لك بزاري مراسل صباح العربيه
زين عيشتك دائما